what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we're here to watch The Last of Us episode
thrust today that's three interests combined
and of course joining me today a man who I love
dearly talk about last of us together all the
time Andrew Gordon how are you I'm doing well
thanks and love you too buddy thank you give this
man a follow ladies and gentlemen it would mean
the world right now if you could leave a like
leave a like to show your support for the last
of us also subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction is up for
the next episode of this show as always full
and threats and watch as long as we sync up
with your own copyright Last of Us available for
a super sexy rejects that's our patrons over at
our patreon page of course covers several things
over there exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included and we launched
a website recently be easier for patrons to
navigate all of our posts that we have over
there as a reminder John and Tara's reaction
for this episode will go up in just a couple of
days they they haven't played the game that's
the non-gamer reactions and then people have been
really enjoying those two the last thing though
you guys might notice in most of the videos you'll
probably see me drinking something like this a g
fuel can because I reached out to G fuel a while
ago because I love their product and I've always
seen these YouTubers constantly promoting g-fuel
and I was like what the heck I actually use your
stuff all the time can I work with you and they
said yes so yeah guys if you want something that
keeps you able to go through the long hours of
the day and help teeth get sharp and focused and
energized and also not crash G fuel thank you g
fuel for working with them while a proud customer
hey guys I'm going to show you a reaction in
just a second but I wanted to pop in here real
quick because as I was prepping this video I
I learned the really sad and unfortunate news
that any wershing who plays Tess in The Last
of Us video game she passed away at the age
of 45 that is just way too young to go but she's
phenomenal in the video game but she also has like
a wide range of other work throughout the years
so firstly I just want to say Annie thank you
for the Fantastic artistic contribution that you
have gifted us with through all this time and to
my understanding she left behind a husband and
three boys right now there's a GoFundMe that's
been set up where all contributions will go to
her family so I have put the GoFundMe in the
description box if you wish to donate yeah it's a
real unfortunate passing but thank you Annie for
everything that you gave us and rest in peace
and thoughts and prayers of their family look
I've been thinking about what you're sorry I
wasn't gonna say I'm sorry nobody made you a
test take nobody made you go along with this plan
don't blame me for something that isn't my fault
you're speaking truths right now
I love how smart she is good change
yeah it's interesting to add that on
he's like straight out of the game love it
I love this shot that reflection yeah oh I
didn't even notice that how'd you get that
scar on your head what is it something lame
like you fell down the stairs or something
someone shot at me and missed see that's cool
you get them no I missed two it
happens more often than you think
shooting or like in general in general
I mean back a minute I gotta
grab some stuff I stashed go
grab supplies check all the drawers
check for notes check for tools no way
you ever played this one Mortal Kombat the
second one there's just one character named
she has monster teeth and then she swallows you
whole and bursts out your bones I could never
figure out how to do that I was similar
to the game but it was a different game
Angel knives I believe it was called is there
anything bad in here just you getting funnier
they're back back and forth sounds so much longer
yeah definitely wouldn't
go down there yes seriously
Ally because Andrew calls her belly
lockers
oh no is that a stalker
oh it's trapped okay yeah you didn't
notice that still makes it scary
I close it's like wow so close to clicker stage
just trying to see if she
has capable of killing it
what you doing homie
oh that's pretty cool
whoa yeah that would be the first one she ever
killed right on the show yeah I believe so
there we go ready in protective
mode I love it kicked over my ass
after this thing makes it mostly
useless you're just gonna leave it there
hahaha you're way too heavy for you to just carry
around man yeah he's gonna say
that thing weighs more than you
you flying one of those whoa it shoved
into a middle C pay 12 bucks for a sandwich
there's something we take for granted even
start if you have to get bit to be infected
then who bit the first person he's like
go look up Wikipedia I thought you went to
school address School teachers how to shitty
government failed to prevent a pandemic oh
so they got into the food supply probably
a basic ingredient like flour or sugar yep
there were certain brands of food that were
sold everywhere all across the country bread
cereal pancake mix thank you that's right so
the tainted food all hits the store shelves
around the same time Thursday evening
it got worse and they're really giving
us the whole backstory here nice Mercedes
the monkeys a monkey references the game
whoa Judgment Day told you you were going to a
qz and you were if there was room if there wasn't
prevention dead people can't be infected
oh wow ah so our prologue is mid lug yeah
is that bill possibly looks like Nick Offerman
not today you knew World Order Jack boot
yeah I'd say that's him
you can see hints I love it
damn so bill was like always
prepared for a scenario like this
The Masks I know we don't get
spores we at least get a mask scene
oh this is so cool we're
getting this entire backstory
it's gonna give us a sense of who bill is before
we actually see them meet him so it's good freedom
someone who Embraces the apocalypse that's funny
resourceful bill
Nick Offerman is perfect for
this camera he is perfect
such a cool Montage he's a guy who Embraces his
Solitude he's been waiting for this
day forever always like this is Haven
yeah the wrench he just looks
straight up just like Bill I love it
there's an empty seat there though bill
oh
he's got traps
yes that reaction I know let me just have another
by mistake oh he is perfect oh yeah
he captures Bill perfectly for sure ah
this is great you barely get to explore
bill in the game yeah you really don't
really feels like this really feels like
it's Canon to what's in the game yeah
Jurassic Park at his place yeah
but not infected ah are you armed is this is
how they met no why did you take that long to
answer I thought about lying for some reason
but I'm just trying to get to Boston it hurt
s to Bruce yeah all those flies
letting down the ladder
you just had that ladder right nearby
green means go I haven't eaten in two days I'm
letting you go so go first my name's Frank oh yeah
nice to meet you Frank if I feed you then every
bum you talk to about it is gonna show up here
looking for a free lunch and this is not an Arby's
Harvest didn't have free lunch was a restaurant
it's got to be a romance between them
yeah for sure yeah it has to be it is
it was even hinted at it it was
hinted at it was never explicit
let's take a peek in there
nice to see the softer nicer side of Bill
yeah I mean he's been lonely for four years
you know they're all wearing
flannel I'm gonna put my flannel
he was so happy isn't that a real home-cooked
meal in years he's like this is better than Arby's
what the [__]
the Elegance
I got you a little nervous huh
and I want you to have some more wine oh
hair back so I guess I'll be going then
oh but first I've been staring at this the whole
time is it antique you know how much
these are worth currently nothing
that was such a perfect delivery
he's not yours my mother's could do
that this is you it's like the game he
doesn't like anyone touching his stuff
I take things
then I'll leave I like him a lot love will abide
make Offerman you're perfect take things and
strive but there's no one at my app lyrics
it's beautiful it was so who's
the girl um there is no girl
oh
wow this is beautiful what's your name Bill
go take a shower bill
wow this is heaven felt love in
so long if you really feel that
it's really beautiful
how dare the camera pan up laughs
the simple things
okay okay
I get like the child decides of Bill here oh
[__] you come on ah you live in a psycho bunker
where 911 was an inside job and and the government
are all Nazis the government are all Nazis
paying attention to things it's how we show
love fixing up some of the shops whoa not
the stupid ones just the the wine shop in the
furniture store wow it's just so particular
about how everything is the boutique are
we hosting formal Garden parties now no
but we are gonna have friends
and we will invite them to visit
there are no friends to be had I've actually
been talking to a nice woman on the radio
hmm you want oh well this really
is just oh yeah it makes sense
oh that is neat what can I just
say on gun aside which I get I
smart way to bring her back I mean I said I want
to thank you he's gotta say another gun hold
you know what let's go inside Tess I want to
show you something oh bills and I like that right
Frank songs oh we get some
Bill Joel moment yeah I love it
let's go Maya mine brought strangers into our
situation I wouldn't be happy either because
cinnamon Tess never had a title stuff we have
an accusing that you don't have here we can't
help each other and get that gun out of my face
it's smuggling that fence got a year on it tops
I can get you 10 spools of high tensile
aluminum last you the rest of your life lives
this is awesome that's such a good expansion you
should use codes for the radio because
he was listening oh that's a good idea
there will be Raiders they'll beat that fence
in your trip wires they'll come at
night quiet and armed we'll be fine
history yeah I didn't I guess I never registered
how long Tess and Joel had been together damn
is when the game started just one more
loop around I got something to show you
not that the first two weeks
are always the hardest bill
oh no way oh I traded Joel and test
one of your guns for a packet of seeds
which gun shotgun a little one huh
foreign love that laugh he gave
wow
I'm sorry getting older faster than you I like
you older I was never afraid before you showed up
oh
it's so touching
those fences aren't gonna
hold up it's like Joel said
oh
oh he feels right it's like the Terminator
foreign
I gotcha I just gotta patch it up he'll be fine
a lot of imagery kind of evoked the Sarah fights
we have copies of all the keys good yeah cool
Jewel you're here you know
I was never afraid but was afraid to lose Frank
IE in a wheelchair
what's wrong with Ryan really
two good job of Aging them
such good makeup that's crazy
guess he got older faster than
build it might have a disease or a sickness
too oh well wow yeah it looks awesome too
oh
the only friends they made were
Joel and Tess which of their
friends do you need besides those
two yeah did you take your pills
oh yes they didn't go to any pharmacy they
want in town I guess or medicine from the qz
big Roundy I love how much time we're
getting to spend with these characters
oh
of him yeah yeah
I guess I just wasn't expecting
that's such a touching story
I knew we were going to get their backstory she
didn't know it was going to be this emotion on
this long it's great I don't want you fall
asleep in the chair I'm not fighting about
it back in bed I promise you I'm gonna
stay up why because this is my last day
I've made up my mind spell
um
every day was a wonderful gift from
God's speech I have had a lot of bad days
but I've had more good days with you than with
anyone else just give me one more good day
starting now make me some toast
you'll wear what I ask we'll get married
oh now we fall asleep in your arms
so we're just not going into my mouth
you love me yes then love me the way I want you to
I always imagined it would end
like so uh angrily between them
they were gonna have Joel and
Tess as witnesses as just for them
the first meal he ever made yeah oh
you gotta get him the wine too he turned it yep
uh
damn the show is so touchy yeah
this is not going right in my mouth
interesting
why are there already pills in the
bottle enough to kill a horse this
isn't the tragic suit at the end of the play
and you were my purpose
oh
I do not support this
oh it should be furious hair at the finish line
but from an objective point of
view it's incredibly romantic
take me to bed
sounds like music from the game
foreign
killed it oh they're phenomenal incredible
they got great chemistry and like
they played the Aging wonderfully
I love the inclusion of this music from the game
so poetic
wow um
that's incredible
flowers not being tended to make sense
it's from Bill to whomever or probably Joel
so clever so they're dead
wow I'm guessing you found this
Jewel because anyone else would
have been electrocuted or
blown up by one of my traps
foreign take anything you need the bunker code is
the same as the gate code but in Reverse such a
clue from a letter uh yeah yeah like a
combination for the lock I used to hate
the world and I was happy when everyone
died there was one person worth saving
that's what I did I saved him then I protected
him you know what to do Joel that's why men
like you and me are here we have a job to do
and God help any mother you stand in our way
I leave you all of my weapons and
equipment use them to keep yes
oh boy
the second one bill crumbled
the note oh man let it out
here to get them in the game huh
he is such a shell of his former self he
can't even like cry over test I have a
brother out in Wyoming he's in some kind of
trouble and I'm heading up there to find him
he used to be a firefly my guess is he knows
where some of them are out there maybe they
can get you to wherever this lab is this Firefly
just like Troy yeah Troy Baker people I'm taking
you with me there's some rules you gotta
follow rule one you don't bring up tests
ever ah just like the game matter of fact we
can just keep our histories to ourselves rule
two we don't tell anyone about your condition
yeah you see that bite mark they won't think it
through they'll just shoot you that's true you
do what I say when I say it yep we clear it's
repeat it say goes what you say goes
straight at the game I love it show it now
let me grab what we can you know you skip
over so many different levels and they
change so much especially regarding the
bill yeah it does not bother me yeah it
is so effective what they've done instead I'm
definitely well we'll talk about it afterwards
dude no there's so many options there's
a wall of them I'm right there with you
seriously let her have one there's even
the small ones there take a handgun
during a pandemic you gotta have toilet
paper I'm taking a shower your shower
oh he gets flashes of Sarah yeah
oh her outfit look at that man yeah
sneak it Ellie
usually see her sneak it hold on you look pretty
it's like I saw in a movie there
were Keys when you open the visor
it's your first time in a
car it's like a spaceship
yeah love it she built such a good reference
yeah she's like what's that
this is so good
might be the first person to say so cool
to a seat belt laying her right up front
Star-Lord put it back Ellie
is
he just smile he's regaining his Humanity
I love this episode oh it's so good
this to me is like this is last of us you know
oh the shot of the window yeah
we won't spoil that but yeah
yeah that's amazing
oh boy
this did not feel like an hour and 15 minutes
that's crazy yeah this show is so well paced
oh yeah oh my goodness that works for me on
every level yeah every level with my eyes
were just kind of watering up like every
10 minutes of that [__] uh yeah they it
I'd be very curious to hear the conversation
surrounding this one but all we can do is
talk from our hearts here and yeah I mean like
knowing the game it it definitely there's so
much different right yeah way different I mean way
different yeah like you and it sets up as as fans
of the game it's an interesting viewing experience
because like you're like all right well so what
happens like uh the briefest version that we could
tell you in the game is like they're looking for
the battery and then running into traps and stuff
and Bill is just like a hardened [__] he is just
the biggest [__] in the world and but they need
to go through like all kinds like this there's all
like sneaking in when they sneak into a not school
and that they do go to school at some point they
go through a school yes but they have to like go
through all this crazy hoops and stuff and running
over it's it's it's it's gnarly fun gameplay and
everything and Bill's awesome and Bill and Ellie
do not get along oh that's my favorite part and
that's probably if as a gamer fan I'm like that's
probably the one part of it I'm like oh I would
have loved to have seen Ellie in bed yeah and and
then eventually they come across um you hear
there's like a falling out with him and Frank
and then they come across and they're looking
for a battery they run into a house and and
um they see that Frank has hung up yeah yeah and
so Frank's already daddy you see Bill get him
what are you talking about um yeah so you see
Frank's uh dead so you never meet Frank in the
game and they allude to a history that there
was possibly something more to them than just
you know buddies uh but it was very like Macho
uh the way how uh Bill comes across right and
so imagine what you saw Bill like at the if you
haven't played the game where you saw Bill like
at the beginning of this episode and he's like a
a more senile uh more uh rageful version of that
more emotionally resistant version of that just
like an older version so watching this I was like
okay well I'm expecting them to when it does
like the three-year jump uh like all right now
we're watching when things started uh falling
apart for them basically yes and I you know
you do set up an expectation knowing the game that
they will they'll have a falling out he's probably
going to leave and and then you know maybe Bill's
going to morph into that like bitter old man yes
and then after and after a while I'm like I
don't think it's going down that path you know
like I don't think they're gonna do that and and
even with the drink I was like okay maybe Frank
picked up on that and switched the bottles around
or something like I kept expecting Bill to to
live still because I'm like there's still so much
with Bill and and the battery and Morgan went on
a mission and everything and they didn't do that
and yet it didn't leave me upset it didn't leave
me angry or like why did you rob us of that I can
imagine I have no idea obviously I have no idea
what people think of this episode yet um but I can
imagine that there will be a camp that is really
bummed out by that and for me I found myself like
no this is I thought what they decided to do for
this show and this narrative it made it more
emotional and poignant and gave Bill a thorough
character Arc and even when you land on the letter
uh by the end which you know like in the game dead
but dead people are always leaving letters
and so the combination yeah in the game yeah
um yeah so yeah the the having the but I like
that when you finally get this letter it's it's
a very like emotional moment and and uh I I just
thought it was it was like this beautiful story
of this couple in the in the apocalypse like
I I wanted to I've had a short story of mine
that kind of was like the last five minutes of
their story a short film in mind it was like a
zombie story so watching it take place and he
never got infected but how they just grew old
together and watching a man watching bill this man
change over time into a person who learned to let
people in and learn to care and even leaving
a letter for like Joel at the end that was so
that was so open and welcoming and supportive
and you could have whatever you want was
like I I think this is perfect for the story
they're choosing to tell and how it motivates
um how it motivates Joel to you know when
he's reading the letter like okay I gotta
apply whatever Bill learned and I gotta adopt this
for Ellie right now absolutely so yeah like they
do they skip over a bunch do they completely
change and eliminate a bunch oh yeah they do
but emotionally to me that's that's what makes has
made this game so resonant it's not so much like
clickers and all that is like it's really fun you
know the gameplay isn't all that like of course
that's a big part of the game but what's made it
so strong this the the game experience is this
this heart this uh this sadness yet this
Bittersweet and melancholic Expressions uh
that's what has made the the last of a story so
beautiful and why it's resonated for so long so
while I miss while I was sure I can miss like
watching gameplay stuff come to life I think
they replaced it with stuff that is so much more
powerful for this live-action visual medium and I
I know I went off on a tangent there sorry Andrew
all right well I I got so much to say now no but
no no you I I agree with a lot of what you said
absolutely look there's there might be some Gamers
and look I'd say like from a gamer perspective
there was definitely a subversion of expectations
for sure in this episode like when you see like
the the three years later and you see them start
arguing like ah here it comes the the the the the
destruction of their relationship and what happens
because again really quickly to like Greg alluded
to in the game basically what happened is uh bill
is so set in his ways he's so like you know he
just he's like basically a homer doesn't want to
leave doesn't want to do anything and Frank wants
to explore and do other things and that's kind of
why he leaves him and so that's a big part of
the falling out of the relationship and he gets
infected and that's why he hangs himself so you
know the we start to see a little bit of that but
again we get that subversion of expectations but
it didn't bother the only thing that uh again was
I wouldn't say bothered I just I know I use this
word a lot uh but I was just saddened by that we
didn't get to see Bill and Ellie but you know what
I get that in the game so it's more of like a wish
yeah exactly but again I get that in the game
so it's not that in the world but because it's
so again like I've said in the first two episodes
I don't mind if you make changes as long as it's
done in a satisfying way and it moves the plot
forward in an interesting way and I thought they
did that really well in this episode like the
chemistry between Nick Offerman and I apologize
for not knowing the actor's name who plays
Frank they're phenomenal together like that
are incredible like watching that whole thing and
I love the way too like in the first two episodes
how we watched uh the prologue at the beginning
just explaining you know how the quadriceps
disease you know kind of uh just giving the
backstory that which was done brilliantly I love
I I call it like uh uh is it Murray Bartlett is
that his name right uh yep yeah Murray Bartlett uh
him and Nick Hoffman they were great together but
I know we talked about in the first two episodes
the prologues which again explain the cordyceps
uh infection the backstory fantastic and we get
the mid log if you will hear in this episode
which again I love linear storytelling when
it's done right and in this episode it was done
beautifully and I love watching that relationship
and even though again it's totally different from
the game when I replay the game now I'm gonna have
this whole backstory of Frank and again even
though there's some changes here and there I'm
gonna have a backstory of the relationship now
of like how they met and the and the bond that
they formed with each other and I I really love to
you you mentioned it at the beginning like we did
get to see that hardened bill at the beginning
like you know just how we how like he's very
untrustworthy he doesn't want anyone touching his
stuff like don't touch the piano don't touch them
that's my that's Bill like for for people who've
never played the game that's bill right there do
it t i mean not as heightened as you would say as
he as he gets in the game not as easy and we've
got to give props to W Earl Brown in the game
he's awesome and the game I love him as as Bill
in the game um but Nick Offerman freaking nailed
in this episode it was so again I just I love the
emotional balance that these two brought uh with
each other him and Murray Bartlett they were just
so good together I mean I was so emotionally
invested but I love the they chose to do this
whole the the whole montage of spending time with
these characters like if you would have told me
before this episode there's gonna be barely
any infected in this episode there's gonna be
barely any action in this episode it's going to be
more of a bill and Frank Centric episode I'm like
curious to see how that's going to play out I
don't know if that's going to work but seeing
the way it was executed I mean was flawlessly done
and also we'd be remiss to mention too I love the
stuff at the beginning the character moments we
got with Ellie and Joel yeah that was great I
love how it's bookended by Ellie and Joel like
the beginning you're with them and then at the
very end you get this experience and yeah when
they checked back in I'm like I I I really you
know I know I've been loving the show but this
was the first episode out of the three that was
so much more different than the game
yeah not not emotionally not thematically
um story-wise but yeah but story-wise and seeing
like a whole bunch you just don't get in the game
it seemed just so like most of this is not in the
game right yeah and and then when you do check
back when that Ellie and Joel I I like that's when
I was like I know I love I I love this show like
it really hit me in like a in a very different
way of yeah this is something truly special and
I also really love that they were able to include
tests back into it as well like just showing that
yeah I forgot all about that but no just kidding
test back getting pick up on her Tessie oh that
was so good because I'm like wait a minute does
this actress look like how she does it in 2023
or 2013. yeah not for sure that was great and
that was I mean I I love that they had that
that communication uh between Frank and tessen
it makes sense like for even though we live in
a post-apop or they live in rather they live
in a post-apocalypse optic World Frank wants
to have a semblance of of normalcy you know
because they do live in a house that where
they do feel a little bit normal but it's still
a post-apocalyptic world so hey let's let's have
some friends over let's let's feel a little bit
normal in this crazy psychotic post-apocalyptic
world I love that that was a really good touch
and we did get alluded to that in in the video
game again obviously for those of you who've
played the game you already know this but for
those of you who don't Bill and and Joel they know
each other they smuggled together they they work
together and test as well so it's nice to actually
see that history format a little bit and again now
you have a little bit of that history formed out
on television for you when you didn't end the game
so again stuff that gets expanded upon just really
smart decision making I mean I I love his show so
but it's so good yeah this was in some ways you
know it there's a there's an element of of it
that because it just hit me I know because that's
the thing is you know when you like test dot it
I'm so I'm so used to like I've seen Sarah die so
many times in the video game that I got my eyes
I like yeah sure I get like emotional watching
it but I'm not like wow I am taking it back or
like test dying I'm just it's like I'm like
oh wow they're really doing this I'm really
feeling this and and like oh look at the change
oh my god look I'm so I'm like absorbed in a lot
of different thoughts because I know the game so
well uh but this was such a different experience
and and I and I and I was like taken aback when I
was like oh Bill's gonna die before he even meets
Ellie yeah that's surprising because he doesn't
even die in the game no yeah he doesn't yeah no
it's interesting and it was it was it was an
interesting choice and I'm I'm just I am I am
in awe of of the experience of this particular
episode brought that it it shined A different
light and I I I'm I'm very curious to see if if
this episode does get like a significant amount of
backlash for such a drastic change and I like but
I I I'm telling you someone who's played that game
um and really remembers the bill the experiences
with Bill and and the back and forth with Joel
and Ellie especially uh this did not bother me
whatsoever we do miss out on some good game levels
I thought we're pretty awesome there's some scary
stuff yeah yeah for sure but it's fun when you're
teamed up with with uh with him yeah and it was
so poetic too seeing the whole Romeo and Juliet
suicide at the end I mean Sopo I can too I love
the uh just just a little reference to from the
game where uh Joel crumples up the note that's
basically when when uh uh Bill found the note
that Joel gave him that said Frank uh wrote wrote
a note very similar to how uh what build in there
and it was very similar and then Bill crumpled
up the note and said the f word Fu Frank and
uh yeah it was just it was a nice little touch
there were some so many awesome touches and then
they included some really cool moments of music
from Gustavo santaolia I hope I said that right
this time guys uh but I love the spaceship line
oh yes yes we we flipped out over the yeah we
won't we won't go into that people we don't want
to spoil because we've been accused of spoiling
a lot already most of the second game they're
flying in a spaceship yes all right Greg spoiled
it they go to Mars in Jupiter and Nexus and when
they get different across and when they get to
Mars they meet Doug Quade Arnold Schwarzenegger's
character from Total I'm in control of these edits
whatever I we I only keep the things that it's
like if we're saying something that's gonna happen
it you know like that's only because it happens
and yeah we're gonna talk about things that happen
in the future We're Not Gonna spoil things for
you guys who have not played the video games
don't worry like we wouldn't do that to you only
Greg but no and uh yeah this was a great episode
but someone might be like they got excited at
this I didn't even play the games I'm like well
what is what is us getting excited to tell you
yeah yeah I know for sure but I mean yeah okay
what information do you have to go off you've got
excited spoiled it they go sipping around fighting
you again it's going to Star Wars what's going
on but to your point I I really am curious what
from the game because I know from the non-casual
fan I know this episode is is gonna be very like
is gonna fare well for sure yeah I am curious
from the gamer's perspective because you and I
are hardcore fans of this as you all know and we
really enjoyed this episode and didn't mind the
changes yeah I was a little bit sad and then we I
because I I love me some Bill and Ellie I got to
tell you if you have not played the games just
go watch the cutscenes of Bill and Ellie that
is damn entertaining to watch they're damn good W
Earl Brown and Ashley Johnson have some damn good
lines together in the chemistry together but again
the way it's done here I get it I get why they
made the changes and it didn't bother me and I
still have that version of the game so it it it is
what it is you know what would it have been cool
if they did that for sure but with what we got
here without the quality of of what we got here
with the relationship of these two and how damn
emotionally invested I was it it didn't bother me
like I If you would have told me this before the
episode and I hadn't seen a thing I would have
said what yeah but after having viewed it and in
the immersive incredible experience we just got
it doesn't bother me as much but I'm curious to
see what other game what other you know hardcore
Gamers that love this uh that love the video game
think I'm I'm really curious I mean I think that
when it comes to this this particular tale that
they told it felt like they told a romance
or like a romance during the apocalypse and
and when when they first kissed and and you
see like they're both crying like that's the
first moment where I was like wow this is really
affecting me because these are like too bad it's
like thinking back on it I'm already getting
like I'm getting emotional again yeah because
um they're they're such they're so lonely
like you and that's the quality that I was
capturing is this this Lonesome experience and and
I loved seeing how Bill first took such joy in the
isolation like this is everything I wanted I hate
people and now I gotta have this all to myself but
then you see over time it does grow weary and
he grows he grows solemn yeah he and then when
they find each other you know good thing Frank's
gaydar was activated and when they kiss and then
the way they're connecting each other like they
found intimacy and you know they found something
that could be special and they could survive
together and to find love in a situation where
finding love seems impossible right like even for
Tess and Joel like it's interesting to juxtapose
them together because I didn't really register how
many years yeah like oh wow look they didn't even
have gray hair when they first knew each other
and and then Joel's so hardened and so afraid
of connection yeah which understandably so but
he's so afraid and so like so opposed to it that
nothing can even bring him to tears about Tess
yeah and I'm like but damn you guys have been
like together for a long time and he can't even
say to like they couldn't even establish a title
between each other like that's too much for them
and I like that Nuance between he couldn't even
say that's my girlfriend he doesn't can't even
call her that you know yeah he didn't really
give it a uh like a position yeah label yeah but
we're not Facebook officials so I can't say yeah
yeah but we're exclusive yeah exactly no but what
I what else I loved about Bill in this episode as
well is he it you know it wasn't just a character
Arc it was an emotional Arc as well and those are
my favorite kind of arcs when you can combine the
two because that's where you get something really
powerful and Nick Offerman I damn that was it did
it's perfect yeah no when I heard Nick Offerman
was coming I was like I could see him as Bill I
could see him as Bill and then we saw the trailer
I was like okay he looks like Bill he looks like
that that's not gonna hurt Nick Offerman I was
like perfect yeah that was the one that was the
first one I heard was like perfect I didn't say
perfect but I said I I could see him I could see
him as Bill I can see him as Bill but then when we
saw the trailer in the first letter okay it looks
like Bill I mean I haven't heard any Lineback he
looks like Bill then when I watched this episode
like all right he's built yeah he's built well the
one they had to really sell you on too was Frank
yeah because I mean they're both new characters
uh you know gamer non-gamer uh if you're not if he
didn't play the game it's it's like the brand new
he's brand both are brand new characters but like
for gamer fans especially I was like all right
let's get to know Frank and I I liked how I do
love that they actually really heavily lean into
the romance between them and they found ways of
finding keeping it very masculine but keeping it
also soft at the right times you know what I mean
not to say that masculinity could not Encompass
being soft you know uh so it was they found like
wonderful nuance and ways to complement each other
and you see why they were a perfect match yeah why
they were a good Yin and Yang absolutely and also
too last thing I want to mention I love that we
got to see Ellie get her first infection kill uh
in terms of uh on I believe it was a stalker that
we saw uh stalker I believe it was a stalker like
a fully formed one yet what stage is stalker again
stalker stage two okay Runner stalker Clicker uh
so there's Runner Runners stalker clicker shambler
if you're in uh is that spoiler you can edit that
um uh and then the b word we won't say and then
there's the r k word we won't say sorry I don't
know how to not spoiled this I thought what were
the whatever the one in the in the game when they
which game are we talking in the first game when
they're coming they may change it but when it's
like in the hotel underground trying to turn on
like the other I think he's trying to turn the
elevator or something not the elevator he's trying
to turn something on Joel it's those are stalkers
but like you see how in here this like I can tell
they're stalkers by what I call what I call by
the Mohawk yeah when one eye is blind like that
that means they're close to clicker stage that's
a stalker okay I guess I've never noticed with
the stalkers that their eye yeah that they have
one normal functioning eye I think both games I
don't think I've ever noticed yeah for sure um
you're trying to get a good look of this stuff he
was playing Silent Hill he wasn't playing I'm not
taking in the designs he's playing Resident Evils
I'm so focused on Surviving in the moment that
I'm not taking into designs yeah I think anything
you just taught me I think I think I just realized
I've never taken in the designs of the creatures
because I'm always like just kill them hey Paul
from heavy spoilers you're not the only one who
can educate see buddy yeah man but you are great
I do enjoy your channel dude um yeah okay guys
uh this is this episode was so good oh it was
amazing this show is so good and you see like um
the the one that's more fresh in my mind is lots
of us too because it's the one I'm more recently
played but like one thing that I I mentioned this
when I think we were this is when the reaction
with the Paul's video have you suppose this
video was when you break perspective and you see
that when you see Ellie snatch the gun like that
happens in the game but you don't see that happen
alrighty guys well thanks for being here what did
you think about this episode of The Last of Us
thanks to G feel for sponsoring this video and
also um yeah leave a like subscribe keep looking
for John Tara's reaction coming later this week